all right every Friday as you guys know
we are taking time to answer your most
pressing questions about the coronavirus
and Memorial Day weekend well it marks
the official start of summer which means
many beaches are opening to some extent
and as the weather warms up more people
are also visiting parks CBS News chief
medical correspondent Jon LaPook joins
us to answer your questions about how to
stay safe this summer John good morning
one viewer question that stood out to me
morning involved pools and chlorine a
lot of us are gonna be looking for
public pools to stay cool in the
summertime is the chlorine something
that will kill the virus or should we be
concerned hey Tony I actually called the
CDC about this I spoke to a physician
there he said yes the chlorine does kill
the virus but the issue when you go to
the pool isn't really the chlorine it's
everything else you're in that
environment who you next to are you
going to you know to a local bar there
you know and getting a drink and sitting
next to somebody so if you're in the
pool alone best-case scenario and it's
chlorinated you're fine there's a tiny
tiny chance I guess if somebody's in the
lane next to you and you turn and you
exhale and that person inhales you know
there could be some spread but really
the risk is is who are you with there
and people in the parking lot when you
go in and out of the building all right
so there's a question now about people
you might be hanging out with it's from
a viewer named Hillary in her state the
regulations prohibit gatherings of ten
or more so her question is well is it
worth the risk to gather in groups of
two to ten I love this question because
I get it all the time now as a physician
and of course the viewers wanna know how
do you even think about risk I mean the
safest thing is you stay home right but
you want to go outside first of all
don't forget CDC says you still do
everything they've been telling you
which is the face mass staying six feet
away at least washing your hands not
touching your face on top of that there
are a few things to think about with
risk one is if you're with one person
you're not just with that one person
you're with everybody they have been in
contact with for 14 days Tony remember
there's a 2 to 14 day incubation period
so theoretically somebody you're with
could feel fine but
week ago they got infected they don't
know it yet because it's incubating that
means nothing no symptoms it hasn't
popped up yet and then one there with
you they suddenly become infectious
remember you can be asymptomatic no
symptoms for a couple of days before you
actually get symptoms or you may never
get symptomatic so that person you're
with is not only potentially infecting
you but anybody who they were in contact
with so if they were in contact with ten
people then you're now possibly infected
by anybody who they came in contact with
if there's ten times ten that's a
hundred people who you potentially were
exposed to in terms of virus the second
thing is where are you so are you in a
state which has a lot of cases a few
cases you can go online this is a great
thing for everybody to know Google the
name of your state and then coronavirus
or covin 19 and you'll be able to see a
map of and and you can drill down very
often to the county where you are see
what the number of cases are and the
last thing is who are you are you
vulnerable use somebody or somebody
you're with are they vulnerable or they
you all know about those groups we've
gone over 2 million times they're old do
they have an underlying problem diabetes
high blood pressure obesity so these are
all the things that help you calculate
risk so there's one viewer who asked a
blanket question that I think goes for
all of us and it is simply is there a
way to safely go on summer vacation
again there's every time you leave
there's some risk but I think it's the
same stuff in terms of what we just
talked about if you go to a motel you
have to think about alright what's the
potential for viruses to be on surfaces
there who's in the motel what are the
state are what state are you in
so I know people want to get out there
and that's fine to do it carefully if
you're in a place where the relative
risk is low it's never gonna be
risk-free yeah and it's all personal
choice and it goes that back to personal
tolerance is for risk so people are
gonna be making their calculations dr.
Jon LaPook thank you very much we
appreciate it